ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد المزيد من
الوثائق السريه اكتشفتها وزاره العدل
اثناء تفتيشي منزل الرئيس الامريكي جوبادل
في ويمنجتون بولايه دلاويرا وفقاء اعلان
محامي الرئيس فاقد كشف المحامي بوباور
انها تفتيش منزل الرئيس الامريكي اصفر عن
العثور على سته وثائق السريه اضافيه تقع
ضمن بطاقه تحقيقات وزارات العادله كما
اضاف محمد رئيس الامريكي انا بيض وزوجته
لم يكون موجودين اثناء التفتيش مشيرنا الى
ان الرئيس سمح به تفتش منزله للتحقق من
وثائقي تعود لفتره منصبه كنائب بلا
الرئيسي في عهد باراك اوباما وتضاف
الوثائق الجديده الى اخرى عثر عليها في
المنزل في ولايه لاوير وفقه ما كشف البيت
الابيض قبل 10 ايام ومجموعه ثانيه من
الوثائق عثر عليها في مكتبها السابق كذلك
في مركز ابحاثنا»
وثائق بيض السريه كشف المزيد منها يضع
البيت الابيض في موقف مبالغ الحرج قضيه
محرجه بالنسبه للرئيس بايطل خصوصا انه
يعتذب اعلان ترشحه لولايه عام 2014
78 يطلب من الرؤوس الى الامريكيين ونوابهم
تسليم كامري بريدهم والوثائق للارشيف
للوطن
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطننا
الدكتور ادم غريب الاستاذ في العلاقه
الدوليه اهلا بيك ومن واشنطن دائما بشار
جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم مع
ضفايا واسمح لي ان ابدا معك دكتور ادمان
تراكم الازمات مواقف الصعبه التي يعيشها
بعيدا هل يمكن ان تقصيه من حلم سباق
الرئاسه تعتقد
جدا
يتوقع بانه بعد فوزه في الانتخابات وبعد
احتفاضه الديمقراطيين بسيطراتهم على مجلس
الشيوخ
والخسائر الخفيفه الطويله النسبيه يعني في
مجلس النواب كان يعتقد بان هذه الثلاث
ستكون سهله همم خاصه انه حقق انتصارات
اخرى في مجال السياسه الخارجيه والداخليه
خلال السنه الماضيه كان يعتقد بان الطريق
ستكون اكثر همم سهله همم اكثر بالنسبه
لترشيح نفسه للانتخابات
الرئيس
حتى الان على الرغم من ان البعض هناك يعني
اعتقد بان همم نرى محاولات من قبل بعض
التيار داخل
الجمهوري
والديمقراطي الذين يرغبون في ابعاد او
اخصاء همم فكل من الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب والرئيس الحالي بايدا والياسباب
مختلفه عن الانتخابات يريدون اخراجهم من
حلبه الانتخابات
ولكن
هناك حديث عن محاوله طرح اسماء جديده في
الواقع
الضغط
هل يمكن للحسبه الديمقراطي ان يقصي همم
بيضا خاصه مع التسريبات الاخيره التي
تحدثت بها بعض الصحف الامريكيه ومفادها
بان هناك استقاله مرتقبه ربما بعد خطاب
بايدنا في 77 فبراير من اقرب الاقربين له
هل يمكن ان يعزل بيض النفس ان يغسل نفسه
المال رئاسه ام ان هذا الاقصاء وقد يكون
امر عليه قد يعطيه من الحزب
يعني
استاذ الدكتور
من كلا الحزبين بان يتم تنحيه همم الطرفين
عن ساحه السباق الانتخابي للاضرار التي
ترتبت عن تجربتين مع الفرق طبعا ولكن هذه
الاستقاله الان او الاستقاله المرتقبه
والاقاله المستركه
ليس فقط رئيس وانما كان معه
همم كبير الموظفين عندما كان نائب الرئيس
والعلاقات معه كانت من مقطع الثمانيات
عندما كان سنه وهذه الدفعه الاخيره حتى
الان الخامس التي تم العثور عليها من
الوظائف تعود الى ابان فته كسندر عضو في
مجلس الشيوخ اني ما بدا في عام 73 هذه
يشير الى اي مدى هذا الصدع بالفعل سيضعضع
ليس فقط اداره الرئيس بايدن وانما ايضا
الهيكل الديمقراطيه لحزب الديمقراطي انجاز
التعبير لان هناك الان تطلع الى تجاوز هذه
الفضيحه التي وضع به نفس يعني للاسف
بمقارنه مع سلفه الرئيس ترامب ولا تنسى
ايضا الاوساط التي تراقب باهتمام هذا
الملف انا الفضيحه بدات في عهد هيرل وزيره
الخارجيه بان فضيحه بن قاسم 30,000 ايميل
كانت على سيرفر خاص
والتجاوب في وزاره العدل وخاصه كان فارقا
بين كيف تعرف الدكتور جرار طالما حظرتك
قربت بين ما يعيشه الحزبه الديمقراطيه
اليوم وما عاش هو حسب الجمهورينا في هل
ترى بان همم تعاقب هذه الازمات يمكن ان
يحدث شرخا داخليا كالذي عشناه هو استبعناه
وشفناه في الحزب الجمهوري
ات هذه تعود مره اخرى وتذكر القاعده
القاعده الجماهيريه ليه الحزبين هل هذا
الاداء مرضي وهل هذا ما انتخبت من اجله
ونلاحظ ان في الانتخابات منذ عهد يعني
اداره همم باراك اوباما الاولى والثانيه
وحتى هذه ما تسمى ايضا الثالثه للرئيس
بايدن كثير مما تم الاعلان عنه جاء مخيبا
للامان يعني حتى في اوساط الحزب
الديمقراطي هناك حاله كمال مول بانه ليس
هذا ما كنا نطمح ان يكون بعد الاستلام
البلاد من الرئيس ترامب الذي استطاع بشكله
وهو باقر ان يوحد كل قوى الحزب الديمقراطي
في استعداد الان هناك بدائل بدائل ليس فقط
تنافس وانما ايضا الرئيس ترامب كما لاحظنا
من خلال معركه رئاسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
يقول الهيكل يمكن ان يتضرر مع تراكم هذه
الازمات على الحزب الديمقراطي وهو يتحدث
حتى عن امكانيه في سما داخليه هل يمكن ان
يتلقف الحزب الامر همم ان لا يخطئ بخطا
الجمهوريين
حتى الان يبدو ان الرئيس الازرق
[موسيقى]
ويقول انا اذا هو تعامله مع قضيه الملفات
والوفاء يختلف عن همم اذا وتعامل الرئيس
ترامب وانه هو يتعارض طبعا هناك اسئله
كثيره حول الى رئيس ايضا مثلا همم
الاقل الوثائق الاوليه اكتشفت الثاني من
نوفمبر قبل الانتخابات بسته ايام وكان
بامكانهم ولكن لم يعلن عنها وكما يعتقل
كثير بان السبب الرئيسي كان هو انه ان اتى
هذا سيؤثر على نتائج لان الرئيس
قراره بالاحتفاظ
بالوفاء كان غير مبرر وخطا كبير ولذلك فان
هناك اسئله او لهذا الموضوع
فقط تفاعل مع حضرتك لما تقول بانه هناك
جانب ما زال يدعم وبقوه بايضا هذا يقربنا
كذلك من الصوره الموجوده داخل الحزب
الجمهوري هناك كذلك داعمون اقوياء جدا
لترامب ولو لم يكن هؤلاء موجودون لما تم
الاتفاق مثلا على مطرقه همم البرلمان
فبالتالي الصوره قريبا لبعضها البعض هنا
سؤال مطروح هل يكون الحزب الديمقراطي اكثر
رغمته من الجمهوري للخروج من الازمه
اعتقد ان هناك عدد من الديمقراطيين الذين
يريدوا الدفاع عن الرئيس ولكن هناك كثيرون
بانه ليس لديه القدرات والكفاءه للقيام
بمهماته وبالتالي اذا فعلا استمر هذا
التوجه وتصاعد فانه سيكون من الصعب على
الرئيس ال الاستمرار وهذا ما يامر هناك
كما قلت في السابق ان هناك من يعتقد قوه
من داخل كل من الكسبان يريد اقصاء
المرشح الاول في الحزب بعض الجمهوريين
والدوله العميقه وما في ال يريد اخصاء
ترامب ويريد الاخرين يريدو اقصاء
ولكن لا يزال لديه حتى الان
42% يؤيدون او بقوه
ترامب يواجه تحديات همم حيث ان اخر
استطلاع للراي اطهر بانها انه لا يزال هو
الاقوى داخل الحزب لان اخر استطلاع اظهر
على هناك عشرين نقطه بينه وبين الشخص الذي
ما الكثيرون ان يكون هو المنافس وان يكون
هو المرشح للحزب الجمهوري هو حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا دي سانتوس وبالتالي فان هذا يضيف
تعقيدات كثيره
للتطورات السياسيه على الارض بالنسبه لكل
من الحسبين لان في نفس الوقت الذي يحارب
كل الحزبان بعضهم البعض وبشاراسه وسنرى
تحقيقات كثيره من قبل الجمهوريين الان
ديمقراطيين ولكن هناك انقسامات وهناك
تيارات داخل كل من الحزبين ايضا فتتصار
وهذه سيكون لها تدعايتها الحمله
الانتخابيه وعلى اختيار المرشح دكتور
همم
حسبان امام تعقيدات وامام تحديات وهنا همم
يطرح سؤال همم الديمقراطيه داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم هل هي مريضه او
بالعكس نحن امام الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
حتى وان كان تشهد انقسامات وتعقيدات التي
نعيش او نتبعها
[موسيقى]
لم تعد بالديمقراطيه وعدت بالجمهوريه
الاباء المؤسسون للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت تاكيد دائما على انه حافظ
على هذه الجمهوريه وبالتالي التركيز دائما
ينطلق من الى اي مدى نبروا بمقوله بان
الشعب يحكم نفسه من اجله وليس عبر ممثلين
وهذه قضيه التي ساعدت الاخيره واستغلها
الرئيس السابق ترامب بشكل سياسي
مشاعر الشعب الامريكي والقاعده في الحزب
الجمهوري خاصه باننا ما نطبح اليه ان نعود
جمهوريه وان نعود بامريكا اولا بمعنى صالح
امريكا الان لعبه الديمقراطيه اشار اليه
ايضا ترامب عندما قارننا كيف يعني لا يوجد
الدعم من الحزب الحزبه اللي هو الحزب
الجمهوري كما يجد خصومه من الحزب
الديمقراطي
عندما يكون
الخطا حظ ذلك في معركه رئاسه مجلس النواب
كيف دائما كان هناك صوت ديمقراطي واحد
يكون هذا المرحله مختلفه قد ينقسم همم
داخل الديمقراطي على بيض كذلك لن يكون
هناك توافق
على الاطلاق للقائد الجماهير والراي العام
في امريكا وسوره امريكا من
الخارجكم جزيل الشكر لنا الدكتور دموع
غريبه